so
so you're based out of silicon valley
yes i think in seattle now actually oh
you live in seattle okay
so intellectual ventures lab is that in
silicon valley
seattle as well that's in seattle and i
helped start the lab in 2007.
i've been working there ever since until
this last year i left to work on some
new projects
okay very cool so question for you would
be
california okay every year
california faces wildfires it happens
over and over and over and over again
you would assume all the brains in
california all the silicon valley brains
would be able to figure out a way to
come out with an invention to prevent
these fires from happening
over and over again two-part question
for you one is the conversation being
had behind
closed doors and two if not why not
well uh the closed doors you're talking
about
i mean i i presume uh i wasn't invited
um but i also think the um you know
people you just gotta look at incentives
like who's incentivized to really
work on that problem and and the truth
is you know
it's a kind of problem that really
doesn't that's the whole reason we have
a government
is to take on problems that are bigger
than people can really do individually
or that companies could do and so but
unfortunately our
you know we haven't incentivized our
governments to to take on those problems
so we have a real problem there and
again you're kind of out of my
jurisdiction
i don't think it's a i mean it's not a
technical problem in the sense that
you know we know what to do to prevent
those types of fires right but we have
to be proactive about it
but you're saying we know what to do
what what what do we do with those fires
no we prevent them from happening in the
first place by
and we by doing you know forestry
management and the kinds of things that
you do to
you have to have some fires is the truth
like you know the
these forests were you know sort of
evolved to get
burned occasionally so you know you've
got to do it but you could do it in a
managed way
which is important when you have human
lives at stake so
i'm making stuff up here but i think
really the right answer is
you know humans have to look and say
okay we chose to live
in these danger zones we tried to make
it
make it so there was never a fire that's
obviously not going to work
so we need to manage and do it
proactively and that just hasn't been
happening in california
it's certainly happening in lots of
other places where we're doing
proper forestry management and things
like that it's interesting what you said
you said that the proper incentive needs
to be in there for somebody to want to
work on and we don't have that right now
in place
when you say incentive do you mean
incentives for entrepreneurs and
innovators to do it or incentives on the
government side
i mean you know it would be really great
so for instance i know inventors have
come up with ways of combating forest
fires
you know rapid response uh where they
can go in
and do much better than we can right now
you know deploying water and things to
dampen the spread of fires um but
there's not really a market
for that no one pays for it in advance
they want to
so no one wants to spend a dime on on
the fire problem until there's a fire
and at that point it's too late and so
we just go through that cycle every year
that's really the reason you want
governments at all is to do the things
that the market can't do well
right so the idea is that the government
should say okay
there's no market dynamic incentivizing
us to fix this problem
um so we're gonna go uh you know so
we're gonna go
invest in that right that's why you want
your government investing in like
diagnostics for pandemics
you know that's why you want them
investing in things like you know
forestry management that's why you want
them investing in the odds of these
things i
i have an invention that we worked on at
the lab
that's the simplest thing we ever
invented and it's a way to suppress a
hurricane
right it costs way less than the damage
from a katrina or some other hurricane
but no one will ever do it because
there's no business model
right so and so
plan a should probably be like move out
of new orleans and get away from the
coast
no one's doing that so plan b
is probably also like move away from the
coast plan c or d
should be like well let's try and reduce
the
the impact that these hurricanes have
and the loss of life
and the property damage and everything
that comes from that
zero government interest in that right
and there's no way that you could get a
make a business out of it because of
what's called the free rider problem so
free rider means
you know uh if one insurance company
pays for it all the other ones get it
for free
right so it's too expensive for the one
to do it so that's where you want
governments to say okay we're gonna
all pitch in and make this happen and
that's that's why we give money to the
government to do those things but
it seems like in a lot of cases they're
not doing it so there would be
so there would be no incentive for
there's not a business model for it
because if you were to be able to
prevent a hurricane
how do you collect the money who does
who pays you the money to be able to go
what else there you go maybe the
entrepreneur what if the entrepreneur
had the business model a guy like
yourself who says you can fix
it and through government grants of
cities
and states that are affected by florida
louisiana texas let's just say galveston
louisiana you know florida that whole
area
gets hit every year how about if they
were to fund
it with a program like that for an
entrepreneur or an innovator like
yourself or an investor like yourself
that would be great except that humans
are only good at doing things they've
seen done before
so a government especially is like a
think of a government is like being a
very very poorly performing human
like the slowest dumbest guy you know
that's a government
and so or at least in america so you
have to
presume that they're not going to be
able to imagine something new
[Music]